hey everyone it's pixar's latest feature
luca
luca did you miss me no not that luca
this one and since i can't actually
travel to the beautiful italian seaside
town of porto rosso
one because it doesn't exist and two i
legally can't leave my country because
of coronavirus
pixar's latest entry will just have to
do so in this video we'll be taking a
deep dive and
yes the puns will get worse into the
ending as well as the film's
many hidden easter eggs but before we
begin hit that like and subscribe button
seriously only eight percent of you are
subscribed so that i can finally afford
a sweet sweet vespa
welcome to the fictitious town of puerto
rosso italy which literally translates
to
red port and you're gonna witness me
totally butcher italian
itself is an easter egg for pixar's
upcoming animated film
turning red but we'll get to that in a
bit we see the fishing boat gao samina
puttering out to sea and the name
gilsamina translates to jasmine from
disney's aladdin the two fishermen here
have a map which pinpoints where puerto
rosso
is located in the ligurian sea which is
located in northern italy near genoa the
place luca will eventually go to school
but notice here the images of sea
monsters it's not even the first minute
and pixar is already setting up one of
the main conflicts of the movie the land
people see the sea creatures as
murderous monsters to be feared
and the sea creatures seed lamb people
as murderous monsters to be feared
you think they come around to meet new
friends no make small talk
they're here to do murders luca teaches
us that we can't judge a book by its
cover that even though we may not
understand someone or something it
doesn't mean that it needs to be feared
but i'm getting a bit ahead of myself
here on the boat is an old record player
that plays giacomo puccini's o mio
babino karo which is all about a young
woman wanting to go to porta rosso
which is strikingly similar to luca
wanting to go to porto russell the
little trinkets that fall into the ocean
like the
cards and the clock are similar to those
found in ariel's trinket cove in the
little mermaid we next meet our story's
protagonist luca a young fish herder
who's completely bored with his life
like ariel he yearns to be free and
explore the land
up above but is held back by his parents
we do not
talk think discuss contemplate or go
anywhere near the surface
that is until he meets alberto alberta
shows him that sea creatures can also
live on land although if they touch
water they reveal their true selves
unlike luca however alberto doesn't have
a family his father actually abandoned
him saying he's old enough to be on his
own
and that's the thing alberto wants more
than anything else to be wanted to be
love
and he gets that through his friendship
with luca however when julie arrives it
puts a serious wedge in his relationship
you see luca and alberto plan to buy a
vespa so the two of them could be free
luca runs away from home and his parents
after he finds out they're sending him
to be with his strange uncle ugo played
by sasha baron cohen far
away from the dangers of the surface
uncle ugo literally lives in the
complete
opposite place that luca wants to go the
deep sea
far away from the light which is ironic
since the name luca means bringer of
light but halfway through the movie
lucas plans change he wants to go to
school to learn more about the world and
the universe meaning that
alberto will once again be abandoned
this causes a rift between the two
ultimately leading to one of the most
heart-wrenching scenes of the film
where luca turns on alberto after it's
revealed he's a sea monster
casting him back to sea but luca isn't
evil far
from it we see the pain in his face as
he betrays his friend a betrayal he'll
later apologize for
he'll see the drawing alberto made
ripped in two and the markings for each
day alberto had been alone without his
father
luca realizes as do we that alberto's
emotions stem from the abandonment of
his father
that everyone in his life that he's
gotten close to has left him this is why
at the end of the film alberto decides
to stay with massimo julia's father it's
a win-win
alberto gets a father figure and massimo
gets help with fishing and a companion
for when julia is with her mother
there's also this extra layer of both
characters knowing what it's like to be
different
massimo only has one arm something he
tells alberto he was born with
just like alberto was born different
being a sea creature
at the end of the film alberto ends up
selling the vespa the one thing he was
working for throughout the entire movie
so that he can pay for luca's train
ticket
he has put his friend before himself the
ticket is an easter egg as well
a113 is the classroom at the california
institute of the arts where many pixar
animators study
even the train number 94608 is the zip
code for emeryville california where the
pixar headquarters are located alberto
and luca decide to travel to puerto
rosso in order to acquire
a real vespa they believe that avespa is
their ticket to freedom even the poster
says
vespa is freedom what alberto and luca
learn throughout the film is that it
isn't the vespa that makes them free
freedom isn't an object it's the ability
to make your own choices and that's what
luca does throughout the movie he ends
up traveling to puerto rosso with
alberto and teaming up with the local
outcast julia to compete in the annual
puerto roso cup which if they win can
get them some sweet prize money for
their coveted vespa it's here we're also
introduced to the main villain
erkoli visconti eckley translates to
hercules and visconti was the name of a
noble italian family which ruled milan
and lombardy from 1277 to 1447.
around town you'll notice a ton of
unique posters influenced by movies from
the era such as roman holiday and a
disney film with 20 000 leagues under
the sea
a poster for fellini's la strata and a
fake movie attack of the sea monster
appear
i like how they even included a fake
actor whose name is really close to
julia roberts
speaking of julia there's nothing more
that julia wants to do than defeat
erkely and prove herself to the town
she's considered an outsider so it's
fitting she ends up teaming up with two
other outsiders
in fact erica lee says fine go start the
club
for losers which a young redhead in a
loser's club just makes me think of it
she vows that she'll be the one to take
down
erica lee so no one's taking him down
unless it's me which foreshadows how
she'll be the one at the end to
sacrifice herself by crashing her bike
into hercules so luca and alberto can
win
luca and alberto stay with julia and i
love how her cat is named machiavelli
after the 15th century philosopher who
is famously known for saying it is much
safer to be feared
than loved a quote which is subtly
referred to when julia says this of
hercules followers they don't
love you they're afraid of you which is
exactly the case as hercules two
henchmen guido and checho
end up tossing him into the fountain at
the end of the movie fun fact the guy
who voices checho is the director of
pixar's the good dinosaur luca's world
is
opened up even wider when he finds out
that there's a world far beyond puerto
rosso
in a great dream sequence he flies
around the colosseum in rome in leonardo
da vinci's flying machine
we even get a glimpse at another disney
character pinocchio who is based off a
1883 novel the adventures of pinocchio
by carol coladi in julia's room you can
even make out a duck that wears a
similar outfit to donald duck with the
cup just a day away
things fall apart for our group of
outcasts alberto is cast out to sea and
julia finds out luca is a sea monster
too
so only luca and julia end up competing
in this grueling marathon that involves
swimming
eating pasta and a treacherous bike race
but luca can't swim like the others or
else he'll be revealed as a sea creature
so he gets in one of those old-timey
swimsuits probably the same one alberto
used at the beginning
and i think these things were also used
in 20 000 leagues under the sea
but where things start to get real hairy
is the final portion the bike race
it's starting to rain and luca is in the
lead but will he risk revealing himself
in order to win
and that's when alberto arrives risking
his own life to protect luca with an
umbrella which ironically
was part of his initial drawing the
previous night luca promised that he'd
win the race for alberto so they can
take the vespa and
explore the world together and now
alberto has come to save the day
the funny thing about luca's pep talk to
alberto that previous night was how the
roles have reversed
in the beginning alberto told luca to
silence that voice in his head that
tells him he can't do things he calls
the voice bruno saying
silencio bruno which is likely named
after his dad who told him to be quiet
now it's luca telling alberto to silence
that voice so that they can live out
their dream together
luca ends up saving alberto from erkoli
and the three race to the bottom with
julia sacrificing herself in order for
luca and alberto to win
however in the process their true selves
are revealed
it's massimo the man who we first saw
cutting off fish heads and with a hatred
for sea creatures who stands up for them
declaring them the winners of the race
it even turns out that the two snarling
grannies from the beginning were sea
creatures in disguise
all along too it just goes to show you
that you never know who someone is deep
down inside people shouldn't have to
hide who they are
luca's grandmother puts it best when she
says some people
they'll never accept him but some will
and he seems to know how to find the
good ones
in other words there will be people like
hercules in the world and there will
also be julius
find the julias alberto and luca give up
their dream of owning a vespa but that's
okay
dreams change and sometimes what we
think are our dreams
aren't exactly what we need for example
both alberta and luca think that they
want a vespa but what they need is
something totally different
alberto needs the love of a father and
luca needs his parents to let go
if you want a more in-depth analysis of
the difference between want vs need i
did a whole video using toy story lord
of the rings and the matrix
as examples which i'll leave in the link
to the description the film ends with
luka on the train to start his new life
fully accepting who he is
watching the isolated island where his
journey started fade into the distance
it's a beautiful moment where the frame
is partly raining with sun shining
through emblematic of our character now
part of
two different worlds of land and sea now
i do want to end on a few easter eggs
that i couldn't quite fit into the main
part
as the racers make their way down the
mountain you can briefly see a planet
pizza toy
story delivery scooter in the back as
evidenced by the planet-shaped ornament
on the top
you'll even see a lux ball which is an
easter egg in almost every pixar movie
that was originally seen in toy story
there's also this boat elena a nod to
the character of abuelita from 2017's
coco
while preparing to test out their
makeshift vespa alberto looks at a photo
of marcelo mastroianni
a famous italian actor who appeared in
many fellaini films we'll also get a
brief snippet of one of these films a
big deal on madonna street
from 1958. the end credits are also
filled with little homages like
julia's mother's dog nerone and the
turtle caligula
both named after roman emperors we see
alberto get a knife as a gift from
massimo
something he wanted earlier in the film
here's a quick reference to lady and the
[ __ ] as well as two fish who could be
dory and nemo and just as you thought
the movie was over there's actually a
post credit scene where uncle hugo
rambles on about life in the deep to one
of lucasfish it's not like a marvel
post-credit scene where it sets up
something it's just a fun little ending
now there is a final easter egg the
director said is out there
but is very difficult to find he said
that it hints at pixar's next film
turning red about a 13 year old who
turns into a red panda every time she
gets excited
the closest thing i could find is this
red panda-like thing here which could
just be an homage to studio ghibli
after all the director said one of his
main influences for luca was studio
ghibli and they even did a film called
porco rosso which is extremely close to
porto rosso but i'm sure this final
easter egg will be revealed in the days
and weeks ahead
i want to hear what you thought about
luca and which easter eggs i missed in
the comments below
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like and subscribe every little bit
helps me
in the channel out for more bad takes
you can always follow me on twitter and
instagram
at thinkstoryyt and until next time
remember
daddy loves you very much
you